prohibition decisions they're rare and
it is the first time to announce to
Prohibition decisions on the same day
the very very large majority emerges we
look at well they're cleared and they're
cleared either because they don't pose a
problem to competition or because that
companies are willing to offer
sufficient remedies in fact over the
past 10 years the Commission has
approved over 3,000 murders and blocked
only 7 and this is this number that we
today are increasing to 9 the mergers
that we are prohibiting villains
takeover of a rubies rolled copper
product business and Siemens takeover of
Austin's rail transport business these
cases obviously concerns two very
different sectors but our investigation
identified serious competition problems
in both we found that the mergers would
have led to higher prices less choice
less innovation the neither of the
companies offered appropriate solutions
to resolve the competition problems our
goal with European murder control is to
prevent the creation of monopolies or
dominant players harming competition for
business customers for consumers and
this assessment includes a balancing of
positive and negative effects of a
possible deal our decision are based on
the rule of law and the in-depth
economic assessment they serve the
interest of all Member States and all
citizens the first case is the villain
takeover of a rubies rolled copper
product business role copper is used as
an input for the manufacture of
automotive electrical or electronic
products for
it is used in the production of
electrical connectors as they are used
in cars in trains and aircrafts the
demand for this type of very high
quality Rolo copper product will
increase significantly in the coming
years and that is due to the growth in
hybrid and electrical cars electrical
vehicle while they require 40 to 80
kilos of copper while cars covered by
and sort of more old-school combustion
engine they only require 20 kilos of
copper and copper products they are also
needed when you do the charging stations
so you can easily see that this is a
market that's growing real and and
Aruba's they are two of the biggest
producers of rural copper products in
Europe the merger also concerns free
world copper strip which is what
actually makes the copper products
the two companies they own the joint
venture called veer metal which makes
this very important input violence is
already a clear market leader in
particular in high-end products for the
automotive sector with the merger
Weiland would have become the dominant
player in the market for roll cover
products it would have been having a
market share in Europe for over 50% with
only one own with only one competitor in
the market with a market share just
above 10% in the beginning august's we
opened an in-depth investigation to
fully assess the effects of this
transaction our investigation concluded
that the merger would have harmed
competition and choice in this market
and have raised prices for in particular
industrial customers Leyland could also
have restricted its far smaller
competitors in Europe from assessing
accessing pre-wrote copper strip with
the merger VLAN would have gained focus
roll over sir metal which is the largest
supplier of Perl script strip in Europe
with a market share of more than 60% so
villain would also have been able to
raise the cost of these smaller
competitors it would have gained access
to confidential information about their
inputs and it would damage the overall
competitiveness in European and global
markets both customers in the car and
the electronic sector and the smaller
competitors expressed strong concerns to
the Commission about the effect of the
transaction on their input prices the
remedy is offered by veal and they were
not enough to address our competition
concerns in particular Benin was not
willing to divest the Erebus stake in
sewer metal and our concerns with
remedies they were shares with market
participants and this is why we have
decided to block the deal our decision
precepts customers by preventing the
creation of a dominant player in the
market a dominant player that would have
resulted in higher input prices for
European industrial customers moving to
Siemens takeover of Alstom's rail
transport business the Commission opened
the in-depth investigation last july to
assess the merger in some sectors like
metros and many other types of trains
there are strong competition besides
siemens and al stone and that is why we
did not have competition concerns in
those sectors
however our investigations showed that
the proposed transaction raised serious
concerns in two areas that would be
signaling system and very high speed
trains when we sit in a plane or more
likely in a train in this case reading a
paper
playing without phone reading a book I
don't hope that rail signalling system
is sort of top of mind but it is the
signalling systems that keeps us safe
signaling systems they are built
installed on boards each train and along
the rails in order to keep the Train on
the right track and all these components
while they work together to make sure
that trains do not collide in Europe we
have developed a common standard for
signalling system called ECT s and that
allows trains to operate safely across
borders the upgrading of the signalling
system across Europe is underway this is
quite an expensive and a long-term
investment for member states and it
requires that the equipment is available
at competitive prices as for very high
speeds trains they are trained that
travel at 300 kilometres per hour or
more the types of trains are important
for the transition into climate friendly
and environmentally sustainable means of
transport rail companies that needs a
very high-speed train while they
organize tenders to compare offers from
different suppliers these tenders they
are relatively rare currently in Europe
there's one big ongoing tender and that
is the HS two in the UK our
investigation showed that the merger
would significantly reduce competition
in several signalling markets and for
very high-speed trains the merged
company would have become by far the
largest player in Europe and in some
signalling markets there would be no
competition left to be clear it's fine
to be big that's not the issue here but
we found that competition from other
suppliers would have been insufficient
to replace the considerable loss of
competition due to the merger
customers including train operators and
rail infrastructure managers they would
have the pride of choice of suppliers
and of products the transaction would
also help European taxpayers since
national and local governments very
often finance railway infrastructure and
we want to ensure that the merger would
not lead to higher prices for the
signalling equipment that keep millions
of European travelers and commuters who
take the train every day safe today
Europe's railway industry is thriving it
has several champions Chiefs among them
Siemens and Alstom they are already
global companies in fact they are the
two largest players globally outside
China for very high-speed trains and
they are the two largest players in
signalling the third being another
European company but our assessment also
covers the future and we looked in
particular into the competition coming
from China we assess the likelihood of
Chinese rail equipments suppliers
entering the market not in the abstract
but concretely the state-controlled
supplier of trains in China see our RC
has more than 90 percent of its
activities inside China it has less
success outside its home market but it
has sold some metro systems for example
in the US however no Chinese supplier
has ever participated in a signalling
tender in Europe all delivered a single
very high-speed train outside China and
there's no prospect of Chinese entry in
the European market in the foreseeable
future Siemens announced and they could
have obtained our approval of the merger
if they had a pro
proposed appropriate remedies to address
our competition concerns however the
companies were not willing to propose a
clear-cut remedy for either mainline
signalling systems or very high-speed
trains we found that the proposed
remedies were simply not enough to
address our competition concerns and we
were not the only ones to reach these
conclusions our findings they are shared
by market participants such as customers
competitors trade unions industry
associations the feedback we received
was negative in both areas signalling
and very high speed trains as regards
signalling equipment the key concern was
the complexity and the viability of the
remedy package the companies offered to
divest a assorted mix of assets
transferring some keeping others
offering licensing agreements rather
than a clear-cut asset transfer as for
very high speed trains the divestment
packet was insufficient because it did
not allow a competitor to develop a
competing very high speed train less
than two weeks ago Siemens and Alstom
made changes to the remedy package this
last proposal did not change the
fundamental characteristics of the
remedies neither for signalling system
no for very high speed trains it was
only limited improvements and did not
fully address the competition concerns
of course and I find this to be very
important it is for the companies to
decide whether to propose the necessary
remedies for the deals to be cleared or
not considering the evidence that we
gathered and we've been going through
more than 800,000 documents including
internal Siemens and internal awesome
documents the negative impact
competition was clear in the absence of
an appropriate remedy package of course
and in the absence of that today the
Commission has blocked the merger these
two prohibitions well they tell their
own story as always we have assessed
each and every one of them on their own
merits looking at the facts in the
affected markets the cases have also
triggered a discussion about competition
rules and their role in creating
European champions competition policy
ensures that we have open and fair
competition in the European single
market
it keeps our companies on their toes
a company is not going to be competitive
abroad if it does not have any
competition at home unchallenged
companies are not likely to be
innovative or flexible efficient also in
the global marketplace EU motor control
allows companies to grow by acquiring
other businesses while at the same time
preserving choice quality innovation and
competitive prices for European
consumers at all levels of the value
chain that be business customers or
final consumers one of the benefits of
the European single market is that we
have room for companies to grow to grow
large without having to sacrifice
competition we keep looking of course at
the precise way our competition rules
achieve these goals we assess and we
re-examine our competition rules and the
processes and we adapt them where we
need it for instance I have launched a
reflection on future challenges of
digitization for the way we enforce
competition rules and I've done that
with the help of independent experts and
of course public input
and the challenges of digitization well
that concerns all sectors of the economy
also manufacture trade and transport so
competition rules are one of the keys to
keep Europe competitive in global
markets but we need to combine several
tools not only to get the full picture
but also to get full effect an effective
Industrial Policy competition
enforcement together with our
international policy instruments and we
must engage in a strategic reflection
about how to maintain an advanced
European competitiveness and authority
at the conference I hosted a few weeks
ago here in Brussels about how to shape
competition policy in an era of
digitalization Nobel laureates professor
Shaun T role he made several
recommendation for an efficient
fact-based
Industrial Policy one of the jet the
suggestions was to focus on market
failure and we do that for example
through our framework for important
project of common European interests in
December we approved such a project in
micro electronics this is a key enabling
technology for European industry which
will be funded by France Germany Italy
and the UK and the public funding will
unlock private investment now we learned
a lot from that process I think every
participant and hopefully now with these
new skills acquired more projects will
follow in particular like the one that's
being discussed right now focusing on
batteries but the thing is we also need
support from research and development
nurturing talent supporting universities
as in our proposal for the multi-annual
financial framework right in Europe
under the leadership of my colleague
Carla smothers is the most ambitious
research and development funding program
ever with a budget of a hundred million
euros and to state the obvious we need
to complete our single market including
the digital single market and invest in
infrastructure we have simplified EU
stated rules exactly to make it easier
to invest in those areas and my
colleague Elzbieta bien Kafka is working
to make sure that European industries
well they stay global leaders in
innovation digitization and
decarbonisation that being said we must
ensure a level global playing field for
European companies subsidy control
outside of the European Union is much
weaker market access doesn't necessarily
go both ways and that is why we work
under the leadership of my colleague
Cecilia malmström
to strengthen the rules of the World
Trade Organization on subsidies and
which is why we have started a dialogue
with China exactly on subsidies but
changes to global rules well they're not
going to happen overnight and in the
meantime it's very important that we use
the tools that we have to be able to
protect ourselves from unfair
competition and these this means taking
seriously security implications for
example from foreign States interference
as regards information data strategic
infrastructure now we have this new
framework for screening of foreign
direct investment that should be used
it's the first and foremost for member
states to use it but it's an important
tool and now we have it we also must
make sure that the possibilities under
government procurement to rule that all
relevant criteria is used and not just
the cheapest possible price and I hope
that we are able to give ourselves a
means to ensure equal market access and
reciprocity in public procurement by
adopting the Commission's proposal on
this so there's a lot to do our work
will continue continue to develop our
rules and our policies to maintain the
competitiveness of the single market
companies must compete on their merits
to succeed both at home and abroad if
companies wants to merge and become
stronger they can do so to the extent
that they are willing to offer remedies
if we find competition issues just like
Siemens and Alstom could have done in
that case our decision today means that
Europe will still have two rather than
one global champions in rail
infrastructure thank you
and thank you very much commissioner
vista will now proceed your questions
I'd just like to remind you that we do
have our very own future looking
technocrats here with us to help us with
a technical briefing which will be
happening after the college readout so
first we will proceed to your questions
relating to the case and then if we have
some time left
Commissioner Esty I will also take
questions on other topics and I will
start probably with Jorge who was the
first person please also mention your
name and your media organizations thank
you with two questions if I miss the
first one you say that Chinese mic make
CRC was not expected to enter in the
European market in the foreseeable
future but in the case of digital
companies it's already a market compared
dominated by US companies don't you
believe that Chinese makers industrial
makers cool dominate and it's a enough
size in order to dominate to control the
global market and then access the
European market in the near future in
the foresee not in the foreseeable
future but in not some long time ago in
the Sun long time sorry and a second
question do you mention at the end
secure in the context of the digital
environment security concerns that
infrastructure and there is another
Chinese company Huawei that it might be
excluded from some European markets so I
would like to get a comment from your
side on whether you think this is the
right decision to take based on this
consent well first on on CR RC asset CRC
has 90% of their business within China
if you look at the global market the
part that's contestable and we are in
agreement with see minam Alstom on how
to define this global markets being the
world except for China South Korea and
Japan Siemens announced on their global
leaders they win most of their tenders
they're very impressive companies if CRC
is to move outside of China and as of
today they run no very
speed train outside of China they will
have to start winning tenders and if you
look at the demands here in Europe when
it comes to security reference high
quality being able to work very
large-scale projects in in a market
where you already have an established
rail infrastructure this is a completely
and much more demanding task than to
build new tracks and have trains run on
these new tracks so when we look at the
very high-speed market we don't see the
Chinese coming where we see there is a
Chinese footprint is in a number of
other rolling stock areas assets Chinese
has as one tenders in the US when it
comes to metros I think in Germany they
have bought a number of shunting
locomotives one thing I can tell you
about chanting locomotives they're not
very high speed and they also do some
rails in some parts of Europe but these
are the the markets where we find
competition as sets in metros and a
number of other rolling stock areas we
have no concerns plenty of competition
in Europe we have no competition
concerns with the merger
so obviously the important point now is
to make sure that those who do tenders
for rolling stock or for signalling that
that they live up to the European
quality criteria in order to get the
best possible offers and when it comes
to signalling and that of course I think
we all appreciate this is a crucial
matter that signaling is a very high
quality and that it is actually
integrated so that trains can do cross
border with no risk for the passengers
the Chinese there are no we're not at
all in Europe they literally have no
presence here and that again comes from
the fact that we have very high
standards it's very difficult to get the
authorization to work in Europe because
we want things to work
gather and to do that in a complex
environment where there's so many trains
already so many tracks already and where
you have the integration as part of each
and every project and that's a very very
difficult skill to master on the
question of of digital infrastructure
that I find to be one of the most
pressing debates at all and I do hope
that we are getting the tool of
screening foreign direct investment in
in a timely fashion that will not solve
it all so there's still be discussions
to be had because very often when
governments they tender out frequencies
they leave it for private operators to
acquire the equipment that they need and
that we have not discussed in detail or
in full yet which is done among others I
think under the leadership of Vice
President unsafe and of course with the
very strong inputs from Julian king who
is Commissioner responsible for security
thank you I think I had dr. Tom next
nope some question Nicholas
I forgot a Nicholas hearse from M Lakes
Commission I wanted just to circle back
to your your closing remarks about the
different tools that Europe has is at
its disposal protects from unfair
competition there's been a lot of debate
about this recently and the Commission
has been Chris harshly criticized for
for the way this decision has panned out
it's do I understand correctly that
throughout the procedure you haven't
seen any indication or
unseen any reason that would suggest
that the competition rules in the future
need to be reformed or changed or
modified to accommodate some of the
concerns that be raised around this
around this process
well I think this is this is a good
strong decision in its own right to make
sure that those who run our our trains
those who are responsible for our
security that they still have the
benefits of competition which is a push
for innovation choice affordable prices
when I look at some of the debates that
we've been having about how to make sure
that European businesses when they go
global are protected from unfair
competition I think we need to find
tools from another toolbox that the
competition toolbox I really regrets
that the proposal to have an
international procurement instrument is
still blocked between Council and
Parliament because one of the things
there is to give us tools to say well we
need reciprocity if you want to have
unfettered access to our markets and bit
in our tenders well we ought to see the
reverse thing happening as well because
sometimes it is as if we have open trade
and fair markets only one way and not
the other and it would be a good thing
to push forward for a much more global
market in itself but with the trade
defense mechanisms if you do for use of
the present procurement rules that has
been quite advanced in order for you to
take into consideration working
conditions sustainability quality
maintenance in the future when things
are being installed when you do all of
that well then you have a different
market pace and you can much better fend
for yourself if you have the fear that
people come with the wrong motives or if
they come having tax payers back home
picking up their bills which is of
course unfair because we asked European
businesses to compete on their own and
on the merits
if a white from Bloomberg was the
Siemens Alstom deal decided by written
procedure without a debate at the
Commission meeting today and if so why
was that why was it taken without a more
discussion between commissioners and
there's been a lot of comments from
Paris and Berlin about how DG Kampf
works do you have concerns that national
governments may try to use the
Commission meetings to exercise
political influence over your work or
even to set up another level I mean one
thing that's been suggested as a council
of ministers oversight for digicomp
decisions well the decisions were taken
today by consensus in the Commission as
always we have had a discussion a couple
of weeks ago mid-january which also
discussed sort of the much broader
picture as unfair competition from other
parts of the world coming into Europe
and how to fend for ourselves and how to
develop European competitiveness in that
respects so my guess would be that that
colleagues are very well-informed about
the way we work we of course stay loyal
to our mandate which is to protect the
interests of European customers and
consumers and it's kind of interesting
that on this very special day where we
have two prohibitions that one is the
prohibition to prevent prices from going
up to one of the inputs you actually
need to make trains and I think it's a
very good illustration of the fact that
a lot of the work we do is actually
enabling European industry to stay
competitive because they can source
input at competitive prices very often
we just think about the end consumer and
not about all the industrial customers
in the value chain in the way to get
there and that is our mandates and it is
there for good reasons because it serves
all Europeans and not just the ones who
host whatever company wants to merge and
that I think is the very very important
thing a second thing sometimes may be
forgotten or underestimated is the value
of the single market because the fact
that the single market is so big
allows companies to grow such a size
that they have the efficiencies actually
also to be global competitors and that I
think is a very important point because
if we didn't have the single market it
would be very very difficult for a
business like Siemens or ask them to get
sufficient size actually to make it also
in the global marketplace
and this is of course why also
completing the single market and in
particular the digital single market is
very high priority
Natalie McNeil is from unlikes I was
wondering what you would say we heard
reactions from interested parties saying
that the Commission had a concern about
for example very high speed trains but
then the divestment the the the
concessions that it was insisting on
would have been much broader because
their production was integrated and -
they couldn't just divest the very high
speed train piece of the puzzle and how
do you react to the idea that they say
well we tried to offer what we could but
to address the Commission's concerns and
not to go further
our concerns to be addressed that is
that is what we want because our task is
not to sort of question the business
logic of the deal is to make sure that
also post murder that customers and
consumers they have the benefits of
competition and since these are very
special markets because they attended
Riven you don't go in and you just buy a
couple of trains sort of of off the
shelves they are custom-made in the
specific situation tend to driven very
long very expensive projects so here in
this case obviously we have given the
parties the benefits of the doubts to
say that what we would need to solve our
issues would be the equivalent of a
divestiture because it has this
different nature but that being said the
equivalent of a divestiture cannot just
be a license to use the technology that
the originator still owns who will
compete against you from day one in the
global marketplace with very little if
any personal backlog R&D all of that
that would enable someone actually to
participate in the next tender and in a
credible way to say I can do a very
high-speed train as well because doing
very high-speed train is not something
that comes easy you have to be able to
do a lot of things in order to be able
to pull that off and to do that in a
credible way and of course your
credibility well that's your entry
ticket into every tender which is why
winning tenders of course is a very very
important point in order to get that
credibility in signalling that's a
little bit different in the market is
also tender driven but there you have
quite a lot of backlog because you have
a lot of installed base already and here
you have basically two businesses one of
Alstom and one of siemens and there
could have been a much more sort of
clear-cut divestiture in this area well
we got a remedy proposal which was a
combination of assets that made it very
difficult to see
that a remedy taker would be able to
take this sort of combined assets and
and make a full viable competitive
signalling business out of it that being
said we had a concern also on urban
signaling and even though the last
details weren't sort of in place the
last easy one dotted that could possibly
have have solved a problem in urban
signalling that would be that concerns
metros for instance but in the to other
areas unfortunately it was not possible
to see our concerns being resolved thing
immediately behind Ethel yes go ahead
you
people are very political I hear some
stakeholders being afraid of possible
retaliation from us immense immense
after the deal will you monitor this and
what advice can you give to third
parties in the future relationship with
the two companies and especially in case
of conflict oh that is that is very that
is very tricky of course we we keep it
confidential when people come and work
with us but since most customers have
deep concerns of course it's not
difficult for Siemens announce them to
figure out who had concerns since they
were widely shared but but I think the
best thing of course is to have an open
marketplace and have transparent and and
of course we stand ready in any sector
if someone feel that there's foreplay
and they're not being treated the right
way of course we have open doors but
that goes for for any sector that fears
that things are not being dealt with in
a proper way
I'll talk lansky with the Financial
Times two questions for you one you
talked about the Chinese competition and
the idea that they weren't going to be
in the foreseeable future and there was
some claims in some of the Agra mergers
that Dow DuPont for example where you
looked a bit further in for innovation
and I'm just wondering how you reconcile
maybe the longer time frames that you
looked at in that with this one or if
indeed they were longer and then the
second question is there's been a number
of mentions of Airbus and and being held
up as sort of the industrial policy that
Europe needs to work towards potentially
with reforming competition rules and I'm
just wondering what your thoughts are on
that
yes you are you're right to say that
merger control is exactly to try to
assess what will happen first murder in
the future so the first thing we do is
of course
go back birth 10 but also five years to
see well what are the marketers how have
the different tenders performed have the
parties competed head to heads which we
find that they have also in in sort of
different types of very high speed
trains they have been competing
head-to-head so we find that these are
strong competitors watched emerge and
we've been looking for the future to see
well what mergers what tenders are
coming up how does this market develop
for the future and this is not just the
next couple of years you need to know
quite in advance what mergers are coming
up in order to be able to prepare your
bidding for for these tenders it's
always difficult to say well is it three
or five or or ten years the important
point of course is to see well do we see
any sign of a Chinese foothold in Europe
well not in very high speed train nor in
signaling do we see a global marketplace
indeed we do hear Siemens and I'll stop
the very strong competitors they're out
there they compete they win tenders and
they do that because they're very good
at what they do and the question of
Airbus it is quite interesting because
when Airbus was created actually it was
the opposite situation as of today there
was literally very very little
competition when it comes to two
airplanes
it was a u.s. affair and very little
European activity that could at all
compete with that
so creating Airbus from the many
different suppliers that came together
to make this now amazing aircraft
company that was actually increasing
competition and I think today it would
have been a pity if we didn't have the
two because the competition between them
is a good thing keeps a mumbler to keeps
innovation coming so that's I think it
is a very good example of creating
competition
well this merger would actually have
done the reverse it would have limited
competition because here we have two not
only European champions but also global
champions who would merge into one
thank you moving away please sir
man I mostly found photography no the
French minister Mayer obviously already
asked for all civic changement off of
the competition rules itself I think
it's not only concerning possible
changes or additional rules in global
context but also of the competition
rules themselves
did you already hear something about
that from the French over from the
German side as well and if yes can you
imagine that Jim given this special case
you have also to do something about the
the competition rules given especially
because mr. Lumia were also already said
that he has and he wants to suggest some
changes No
so far we have seen no French proposal
to that effects I don't think that this
case is a prove that we need change of
competition rules we may want to change
our competition rules if we want to be
sure that we are also served well by the
markets when we all becomes more digital
and and I'm very careful not to sort of
put digital in a corner to say well this
is just about digital digital because
this is very much about how do we ensure
a level playing field when access to
data becomes the ups and downs and being
able to compete if you look at the car
industry this will be a very very
crucial matter for the car industry to
access data actually to learn cars to
drive themselves to feed the artificial
intelligence in there in a sufficient
manner
and in that we need to reconsider how
does our competition rule allow for that
to happen and this is I think one of the
examples of where you see sort of
manufacturing that then leaps into a
digital area where we need competition
was to support this so I think a lot of
questions needs to be answered
over the next month in order for the new
Commission to be able to deal with that
the good thing is that we have started
that process already in order to be able
to make a strong recommendation for the
next commission the thing is that when
it comes to the sort of the very
fundamental value of competition policy
it is there to serve consumers and I
haven't heard anyone question that very
basic but it would also be a very
extraordinary thing because in our
international competition Network this
is the basis that every every
competition authority everywhere on this
planet is is working to this is our very
basic to protect the customers so of
course change will come for me the
important point is of course to make
sure that it's changes that still make
sure that the market serves us as
citizens in our society in our role as
consumers or customers that be in an
industry in a business or final
consumers as we are as individual
citizens thank you mark and then right
behind
good afternoon mark paper corn Foster
Netherlands I'm especially the last few
months the German and French ministers
have been quite vocal publicly about
what you should do should approve the
the merger if not mr. DeMaio said even
the EU would actually stop to exist were
you surprised by the level of this
pressure and secondly did it play any
role maybe also in a reverse way in your
decision of today Thanks but the thing
is in in in a merger like this there are
customers all over Europe people who
commute by train every day national rail
operators who do their best to make
trains run on time signalling issues
that has to be solved in order to
modernize our entire rail industry and
of course you're right to say that the
interest of this murder has been very
very high from France and Germany but
there is still 26 other member states
who have an interest in this market and
when we see the the responses to our
queries the letters that we have
received we see there's a lot of
interest from others for us to make sure
that prices do not go up that makes it
more difficult for national authorities
to modernize their railway system for
them to have actually competitive
tenders to have the best possible price
for their trains and and that means a
lot to me as well that not only those
who are very local also in in the media
being heard but also those who have a
number of concerns who writes to us who
comes to my office to state their
concerns about mergers like this and I
think it is important because when you
have a single market and you have big
successful European companies they do
not only serve the countries where they
have their home they serve all of Europe
and that's of course it's important
staying yeah just chemical at different
Park just back on the remedies we've
been talking about a clear-cut
divestiture was there a possible remedy
here was it even discussed and what was
this clear-cut divestiture that would
have solved the problem well at this
stage it's always difficult to say we
tested the remedy package in a market
test and got a very negative feedback
and when when we do that and the
negative feedback is then there then we
need a clear-cut remedy in order to do
away with our competition concerns which
meanings that when we have time things
can be may be more complex more nuanced
because we have you know time to make
sure that we know exactly how things are
going to work that this can be pulled
off that it will be viable that someone
can take it and they can be a real
competitor if that cannot happen because
the market test is negative then we need
something more clear-cut to make sure
that we absolutely happy and we know
that we're going to work and and it
wasn't the case in this case assets on
the previous question this is a special
market it is tender driven it's very
very technology intense so of course we
were ready to accept a remedy proposals
that might have been somewhat different
from what one would think of as a
traditional divestiture of a full going
concern but we were never offered
something that could actually do that
assets in signaling mainline signaling
the remedy was very complex it was very
tricky to see that work and in very high
speed it was a licensing of a technology
with some limitations that made it very
difficult for us to see that someone in
the future and of course preferably in a
near future actually could could make a
very high-speed train and compete with
the merging parties thank you yes
we do we modern accuracy yes hello
commissioner
I come from Disick who I'm going to put
my question in French now our Paris has
made a number of comments about possible
changes in competition rules and they
have said that two more behavioural
remedies that could be authorized in
other words authorizing a sale but
hedging that about buy more monitoring
and control of actions which had taken
this would represent a quite a major
change in philosophy what do you think
of that idea
well I was so probably understand the
entire beginning but then you speed it
up and I lost you would you repeat your
question microphone please okay but
police say we need to allow more
comportment ARIMA DS it means not
forcing the companies to sell some part
of their activities but monitoring them
better so you can have by the same time
a giant company and take care that they
do not have any abuse on competition or
prices that you can have both sighs well
it's it's not at all not to appreciate
what bureaucrats can do but I think the
market is a much better supervisor
then than someone monitoring what is
going on and then maybe having to
untangle things and of course the the
paradox or the dilemma here is that for
huge parts of this merger
we had no concerns in in metros in a
number of other rolling stock issues we
had no concerns in urban signaling they
were to be solved but maybe to give you
sort of a sense of the figures we're
talking about the remedy that we maka
tested it had a value of four percent of
the turnover of the merged entity
well we where we've had other tricky
mergers like the ball Wrexham there the
divestiture was twenty percent of the
turnover of of the merged entity in bio
Monsanto it was ten twelve percent of
the merged entity that was divested so
so the paradox here is that we have a
larger which for large parts are
uncontroversial from a competition point
of view we have two very specific issues
that cannot be solved because the
problems are big and the solution
proposed they're too small and that of
course some degree is a pity because
it might have been possible but it's not
for me to judge it's for the companies
they take the decision as to whether or
not they want to propose remedies that
will solve the concerns or not and I
said when I look look back I find that
the the best murderers are those where
there's been a structural divestiture
where things have been actually solved
because if you need to monitor the
market and look into and you have
behavioral commitments saying I will not
do this or I will do that then you know
you need the weight of an angel actually
to make sure well what is actually
happening here and who said what and did
what in what market because the the
thing of the market is that it's each
and every one of us the market is not
something invisible the market is not
something magical the market is just
customers and consumers saying what they
would like to buy and if they're not
happy with the price of the quality of
the services they go to someone else
and that is the most and best efficient
monitoring that you can have that
customers are happy thank you thank you
sitting at the back with the cool kids
youichi
High Commissioner for you and she from
Reuters what is would you say yeah
definitely not a short-sighted
short-term technocrat thank you
hi would you say that yeah definitely
not a short-sighted short-term technical
which some people have said that the
Commission is
thank you where is another batch of
Honor here we're not supposed to be
political we're not supposed to sail
into one side of the other side we're
supposed to look at the facts of the
case but we have a very very clear
value-based mandate to make sure that
the market serves consumers and
customers and for me that is very
important because there's also an
element of democracy here that
businesses know that they are in there
as long as their consumers as their
customers like their products and that I
find is a very strong mandate and that
shouldn't be tainted or interfered with
because of of the day-to-day politics
and and the reason why I think so is of
course that it has served us well so far
I think from top of mind Europe has a
surplus in in manufacturing two hundred
and eighty billion euros 2017 never have
so many Europeans had a job seven out of
ten the fact that we have a big single
market that actually works and fair
competition within is producing amazing
companies very strong industries and a
lot of jobs that being said we're not
done there's a lot of things to do
because we should not accept unfair
competition from the outside we should
not accept that our businesses are not
allowed in in other markets when we
allow businesses from other markets to
come here so no room for complacency but
I think that that the work we do here to
service all that is of the essence and
that is of value for each and every
member state and each and every citizen
I take maybe a couple more Beliveau tea
on something else anything else on this
topic before I open it up okay
Kalavati go ahead still on this okay
Kalavati and then dr. tom
but after NACA Michigan about ending
Cronus Italy just two questions if I may
the first one is on German bank North
Alby which was rescued if I'm not wrong
by two German lender neither Saxon on
the success Saxon Honnold and by an
inter banking public fund I wonder if
the Commission is looking at this case
because it apparently seemingly did not
happen at market conditions and the
second question if I may is on are
Italia just to know where we are you
have an open investigation on the ridge
alone i guess that the competition is
going to assess the whole package
although even with the deal which is
going to happen may you say something
about this thank you
on the first question you're right we
are in contact with authorities on the
question of NLB but obviously no
conclusions on the Alitalia the state
aid investigation is still open you
probably know that repayment of the
bridge loan has been prolonged it may
eventually also develop into a double
operation of the state aid operation and
a murder assessment but all of that
remains to be seen we have no
conclusions yet
thank you Tom
don't make it a pound yes em it's on
Germany is this murderer or whatever it
is between RWE and a on which has been
notified to you could you tell us a
little bit how you see this problem and
is there any chance that you give this
back to the German competition
authorities yes this it is it is ongoing
I think it's still relatively early days
so I have no comments on substance and
as far as I know that's a serious
limitation we have had no questions to
refer it back to Germany thank you that
concludes our press conference
commissioner thank you very much
commissioner and Juke itis and
Commissioner Gabriel will be joining us
soon for the college readout and I
remind you that once that is concluded
we will have a background technical
briefing with the experts for any more
technical points on these two cases so
I'll see you shortly for that thank you
[Music]
you